paul is capable of throwing some decent
combinations and has done it from time
to time just haven't been oh
ouch
that had to hurt
jake paul dominated his rematch with
tyron woodley on saturday at the emily
arena in tampa florida before the fight
he told et he was feeling the best he's
ever felt i'm better than ever and had
an amazing training camp switched up a
lot of things i'm 10 pounds lighter
brought in a nutritionist so just
everything is better the rematch which
was titled leave no doubt followed their
first match in august where paul won by
split decision you know for me the last
fight answered a lot of the unanswered
questions that i even had about myself
but this time around he left no doubt
alright the youtube returned pro boxer
knocked out the former ufc champion in
the sixth round
but to cut woodley some slack with just
two weeks notice he stepped in to
replace paul's original opponent tommy
fury who withdrew due to a broken rib
and a chest infection he is the winner
by way of knockout and still undefeated
the problem child jake
[Applause]
you heard that right as of now paul who
made his pro boxing debut in january of
2020 remains undefeated here's what the
24 year old told et he hopes people take
away from his winning streak so many
influencers like tick tockers youtubers
we get labeled into a box and people
don't
think we can do anything outside that
box they don't think you're talented
they don't think uh you can accomplish
anything and if you try to go into a
different vertical all of a sudden
you're criticized
so i want to be the example for them
influencers ticktackers youtubers that
don't take no for an answer you can go
into wherever it is that you want to go
and work hard and accomplish whatever it
is that that you want
and i i'm the prime example of that
because coming into this
as a youtuber coming into professional
boxing they're saying oh he's a youtuber
he's a youtuber we don't we're not
taking him seriously well what if i was
what if i was just uh
a landscaper and i wanted a box no one
would say oh he was a landscaper you
couldn't buy so why is it that since i'm
a youtuber
i can't box and that's just the point
i'm trying to
show people
[Music]